in recognition of earth day we are going
green with las vegas weekly staff writer
cindy moon reed joining us via skype to
share some tips to
help yourself help our environment hey
cindy how you doing today
i'm great happy earth day that's right
and we're going to start with the basics
for folks okay you've got some great
reminders
about how to recycle and do it properly
get started there cindy
there's a few basics first of all all
those plastic bags sandwich bags
if it's flexible plastic it's not
recyclable so
just go ahead and use them as a trash
bag instead
and then also remember to rinse out any
food
food stuff you can't have any organic
material in your recycling
so it's not composting and a final tip
is no wish cycling
so just because you wish it could be
recyclable
doesn't mean it is so any like bowling
balls
toys your old wardrobe just go ahead and
donate that rather than
setting it on your curb such an
important point when we talk to republic
services they say you wouldn't believe
what comes across here
in the facility and we want people to
contact the
big brothers big sisters the other
organizations and non-profit salvation
army goodwill
that you can recycle those clothings
and do what you say like there's no wish
cycling you guys got to take the next
step because they're not going to be
able to do that for you
all right what about cutting a mission
cindy so
i mean i guess first of all you could
just stay home continue working from
home like we always
are but if you are going to hit the road
try to carpool whether that means
driving with a colleague or friend or
even sharing a cab
or uber definitely riding our public
transit
is super helpful for the environment and
then looking forward we have
the potential to get light rail and
trains coming through vegas
and so anything you can do to
politically support
those future developments will help
down the line all right and last but not
least folks we live in the desert we got
to make sure we conserve our vital
resource of water
that's true so that means you've got to
repair any leaks
make sure there's no dripping faucets
make sure that
you know if you have a lawn maybe and
you're not using
it maybe you're better off with some
astroturf
obviously turn off the tap when you're
brushing your teeth
as they like to say it's a desert out
there be water smart
it's very very true thank you so much
for joining us cindy we appreciate that
and
folks make sure to grab a copy of this
week's green issue you'll find all the
information
cindy has mentioned in las vegas weekly
again thank you cindy and we'll talk to
you soon